[Music]
Cloud logging empowers you to manage
analyze Monitor and alert on logging
data and events in real time however
there are times you may want to collect
and store logs in a different place for
later analysis this is where log syncs
can be really helpful in this video
you'll learn more about what log syns
are when you can use them and how you
can create them at project folder or
organiz ation
level log syncs give you the power of
choice and control over where your logs
are stored they can be stored in Cloud
logging or exported to other Google
Cloud products for
analysis log syncs allow you to Route
logs to these supported
destinations let's understand how log
syncs work the logs router receives logs
as they arrive and then for each log
sync the log router compar URS the log
to the filters on the sync when a match
occurs the log is routed to the
destination specified by the log sync a
lock can match filters in multiple lock
syncs you can use lock syncs for sever
scenarios for example to enhance your
querying ability to store the logs long
term or to stream logs to a third party
you can also configure log Sy to exclude
a class of logs that you don't need to
store all right now let's take a look at
a couple of real scenarios where log
syncs can be useful imagine you have
virtual private connection or VPC flow
logs enabled on multiple projects you'd
like to easily query and run analytics
on these logs in one place the best way
to achieve this is to create a log
bucket in a project dedicated to storing
logs then configure a log sync to send
all VPC flow logs from all projects to
that
bucket from there you can upgrade the
the log bucket to log analytics which
gives you many coring and analytics
functionalities now let's say you don't
need your logs in Cloud logging but you
still want to query the logs data along
with other app and business data that
only existing bigquery data sets in that
case you directly send your logs to
bigquery let's now dive into a demo and
create a log sync to Route logs to bit
query in Google Cloud console before we
begin make sure the big query data set
that you like to rout the logs to is
created since we like to create an
aggregated sync at organization level we
need to create the sync at the
organization logging
page specify a name and clear
description for your
sync select big query as a Destination
type now you may notice that when we try
to select the specific bqu data set it's
asking for the absolute path of the data
set the data set we like to to use in
this case is called VPC flow logs and is
in Project Central
logging you can choose to partition your
data by day to improve query
performance don't forget to make this an
aggregated sync by selecting the option
to apply this configuration to all child
resources now we get to the exciting
part here we can configure which group
of logs we want to include in the sync
and what subset of those we you like to
exclude if
any VPC flow logs have a specific log
name ensure to include that in the
filter it's recommended that you try and
preview the logs and verify the filter
is working correctly however since we at
organization level we don't expect to
see any
matches if you know that there's a
subset of APC flow logs that don't
provide a lot of value and are not
needed for analyzing the logs data then
you can add an exclusion filter to
exclud those logs from being routed to
the destination data set and avoid
unnecessary
charges click create sync but we not
done yet for the logs to show up in
bigquery make sure the unique identity
writer or the sync service account has
the necessary permissions to write logs
to the destination data set to do this
copy the unique identity writers or the
syns account ID navigate to the big
query data set on the destination
project click on
share and assign a unique identity
writer the big query data editor
role
let's verify if the logs are getting
exported to
bigquery click on VPC flow logs data set
and then on
preview woohoo all the logs are coming
in to learn more about log Sy check out
the following documentation thanks for
[Music]
watching